bonjour et bienvenue à New York
bienvenue sur France 24 et sur Radio
France Internationale nous sommes à
l'Assemblée générale des Nations Unies
et notre invité est le président de
Guinée Bissau ou Marot Sissoko m'balo
c'est aussi le président en exercice de
la Communauté des États de l'Afrique de
l'Ouest la CEDEAO et avec moi pour cette
entretien Christophe bobouvier de RFI
monsieur le Président bonjour bonjour
monsieur le Président que vous avez
convoqué ce jeudi ici à New York un
sommet extraordinaire de la CEDEAO
pourquoi cette décision donc ce premier
sommet qu'on va faire depuis que j'ai
appris et que j'ai pris la fonction de
président d'exercice de comprendre de
chef d'État du gouvernement pour
réexaminer la situation de notre
sous-région notamment la citation de la
Guinée et celle du Mali
parce que on n'a pas une grande rangée
avec Burkina Faso les choses se passent
très bien en Burkina Faso il respecte
les feuilles de Ruth le calendrier
donc
pour cela que j'ai convoqué cette
réunion qu'on puisse voir
c'est des dossiers en particulier mais
ils sont quand même qu'il y a un
troisième dossier qui motive cette
réunion c'est le dossier des soldats
ivoiriens détenus au Mali est-ce que
c'est le président ivoirien Alassane
Ouattara qui a poussé pour que cette
réunion se tienne et que ce dossier soit
aussi à l'ordre du non non pas du tout
pas du tout pas du tout ça c'est des mon
initiative
de convocation mais parce que c'était
une chose traditionnelle
je pense cette question sera quand même
abordée évidemment mais c'est pas
Président
c'est le président en exercice qui est
convoqué ce sommeil que son retrouve
pour voir quelle est la situation de
notre sous-région mais évidemment qu'on
va discuter ces sujets aussi alors
depuis le 10 juillet il y a donc 46
soldats
ivoiriens qui sont détenus au Mali
d'après Bamako ce sont des mercenaires
mais d'après Abidjan on dit que ce sont
des otages parce que le Mali en échange
de leur libération réclame aujourd'hui
l'extradition de trois opposants maliens
réfugiés en Côte d'Ivoire alors quel est
votre opinion plutôt des mercenaires ou
plutôt des otages bon moi je pense que
ce sont pas des mercenaires on vient de
voir écouter même hier avant-hier le
déclaration de secrétaire général des
Nations Unies
qui sont pas des mercenaires moi je
pense que il faut on peut on pourrait
résoudre ces situations
de côté malien on est en train de en
Afrique aujourd'hui parce que les cas
de ces 48 au 49 soldats
ivoiriens au Mali l'Allemagne nous a
bien expliqué que
ça fait trois ans que ces gens le fait
prestation de service donc c'est canal
donc on peut pas qualifier ces gens de
mercenaires
mais
les autres maliens qui vit en Côte
d'Ivoire
ils sont pour lancer le mandat d'arrêt
juste après ça ça peut quand même on le
trouve pas quand même
je n'arrive pas à trouver le mot
complexe USA mais moi je pense que quand
même on pouvait éviter les pires avec
ces situations moi dans la place de
Maliens je pouvais relâcher ses 49
soldats c'est à dire que vous n'êtes pas
d'accord pour que il y ait un échange
entre les soldats ivoiriens et les
opposants maliens c'est ça bon c'est pas
moi d'être d'accord ou pas mais moi à la
place de Maliens je vais pas mettre ces
conditions alors justement il y a eu ces
dernières semaines des tentatives de
médiation il y a eu le Nigéria il y a eu
notamment le Togo sans issu pour le
moment à part la libération de trois
femmes soldats mais il y en a toujours
46 qui sont détenus alors très
concrètement est-ce que vous avez
récemment parlé au colonel assimigoïta
de cette question est-ce que ici à New
York vous allez rencontrer le chef de la
délégation malienne le Premier ministre
par intérim Abdoulaye Maga pour essayer
de dénouer ce problème non c'est pas
prévu depuis que j'ai pris la fonction
de président en exercice j'ai pas oui
aucune contact avec guitare c'est pas
bien
donc c'est pas prévu aussi que j'ai
rencontré la délégation malienne vous ne
voulez pas leur parler non mais bon moi
je suis président de la CEDEAO donc je
peux pas me radicaliser pour dire que je
peux pas parler en paiement de la Cedeo
même s'ils sont expulsés mais ça c'est
dans la conférence les choses de la
CEDEAO mais on peut pas les expulser
aussi qui est pas le dialogue parce que
aujourd'hui en tant que président en
exercice je dois parler avec tous les
États membres
vous avez pris la présidence de la
CEDEAO au moment où cette organisation a
levé les sanctions économiques et
commerciales contre le Mali c'était au
début du mois de juillet
si on n'arrive pas à régler ce problème
des soldats ivoiriens des tenues au Mali
est-ce que de nouvelles sanctions
pourraient être mises sur la table ou
pas bon tout est possible tout est sur
la table mais comme vous le savez moi je
suis que le représentants de tous les
chefs d'État c'est comme ça qu'on
fonctionne à la CEDEAO c'est pas moi
parce que je suis présent en exercice
que je leur prendre en décision on est
latérale il faut une conscience de tous
les chefs
bon moi je vais pas en parler trop par
rapport ce sujet parce que je suis
prenant un exercice je dois d'abord
écouter c'est pour cela qu'on a convoqué
une sanction mais quand même moi ma
position personnelle
je pense que c'est d'ailleurs Ouattara
s'est permis des chefs d'État qui ont
demandé d'une manière insister pour
qu'on lève les sangsues au malien il y a
trois mois
c'est parmi c'est permis de chef d'État
qui ont demandé pour les
bon je dis pas oui ou non mais moi je
dis juste que
ce président Ouattara il est permis de
chefs d'État qui ont demandé pour lever
l'essentiel comme moi je suis le premier
chef d'État qui est parti au Mali j'ai
assisté le serment de président Bada
quand vous dites que tout est possible
c'est-à-dire que des sanctions de
nouvelles sanctions ne sont pas exclues
c'est ça non pas ce que c'est pas juste
par rapport à ces situations de 49
soldats ivoiriens on va examiner aussi
depuis qu'on a levé les sanctions
nous sommes beaux parce qu'on ne peut
pas quand même banaliser aussi notre
organisation à se régionale il faut que
les gens comprennent que il y a des
principes de la CEDEAO donc tout le
monde doit suivre cette principe
justement vous avez dit tout à l'heure
qu'avec le Burkina ça se passait bien
avec le Mali on voit que c'est compliqué
il semble que le pays où il y a eu un
putsch avec lequel c'est le plus
compliqué c'est la Guinée vous y êtes
allé vous avez demandé un chronogramme
de deux ans pour une transition la jinte
dit non c'est 3 ans on ne bougera pas
est-ce que là on a un blocage complet
non non pas de blocage je pense pas que
les gens t'as dit que les trois ans j'ai
pas entendu ça je ne parle en six mois
il l'aurait affirme alors ça je pense
que donc il y a une compréhension de ça
ça c'est une acceptable pour la CEDEAO
inacceptable et négociable ça veut dire
que si la jante maintient 3 ans là pour
le coup il y aurait des sanctions
absolument absolument l'oursin
donc
c'est une conditionnel ça on peut pas
accepter ça
vous échangez avec lui ou là aussi les
ponts
j'étais là-bas comme je vous dis dès que
j'ai appris la fonction j'étais dans des
pays j'étais au Burkina
et
en Guinée
on a discuté on est arrivé en
concessions que on peut pas dépasser les
24 mois ça c'est négociable pour la
CEDEAO oui mais une fois que vous avez
dit ça que le colonel Doumbouya était
d'accord pour 24 mois les autorités
guinéennes ont démenti elles ont dit non
non c'est 36 mois bon tout ça on va le
voir après demain pendant notre sommeil
là on va voir quelles sont les
dispositions de dispositif qu'on va
prendre par rapport à ça mais une chose
que je peux vous assurer c'est
négociable de la part de la CEDEAO le 36
mois le 28 juillet dernier Monsieur le
Président lors de la visite du président
Macron dans votre pays vous avez annoncé
que vous souhaitiez la création d'une
force anti-putch au niveau de l'Afrique
de l'Ouest c'est vrai que vous-même avez
été victime d'une tentative de coup
d'État il y a six mois abyssao mais
concrètement comment empêcher l'armée
d'un pays de renverser son gouvernement
moi je pense que c'est des modèles là
apparemment non mais c'est dommage que
ça arrive qu'en Afrique l'Ouest
aujourd'hui
et là il faut quand même pour moi que je
pense c'est très important de créer une
force tous les États membres de créer
une force est-ce que arrivé au pouvoir
c'est pas un
et le norme il faut les
et la démocratie sinon on enlève la
démocratie on enlève les élections ça
sert à quoi ça sert à rien c'est pour
cela que moi j'ai proposé tous les États
membres politiques d'envoyer les soldats
de manutention d'interposition il faut
créer une fonction publique et même
saisir le cours pendant l'international
mais est-ce que est-ce que vous avez
vous allez mettre cela formellement sur
la table de la CEDEAO absolument
peut-être là ici tout à fait
donc pour voir ces citations parce que
sinon c'est pas la peine qu'on fasse les
élections ça sert à quoi ça sert à rien
c'est quelqu'un ça lève une bonne
honneur le matin faire un
une force commune aucun pays alors ouais
merci monsieur le Président de nous
avoir accordé cette entretien et merci à
vous de nous suivre sur nos deux chaînes
France 24 et Radio France Internationale
[Musique]